une première un plaisir la ville a
accueilli ce samedi 3 et dimanche 4
février un tournoi d'ultimate 100%
féminin baptisé rôti un rendez vous
organisé par le club de frisbee local
vraiment que le que le sport en tout cas
l'ultimate féminin freine sa place au
sein de ce sport qui est déjà mixte et
on souhaitait à cette occasion de
regrouper les filles est également
d'échanger en se regroupant choix
ensemble pour cette première édition une
cinquantaine de joueuses venues de toute
la région parisienne a répondu présent
cinq équipes ont pu être créés se sont
affrontés pendant deux jours on accepter
parce qu'assez peu de tournois féminins
en france on a du mal à en trouver
maintenant il y en a de plus en plus ces
dernières années notamment en or parce
que les équipes sont plus restreintes
donc c'est plus facile en france et
beaucoup de mixte et c'est parce que je
pense qu'il n'y a pas à cette fille pour
faire des équipes des ploucs on s'équipe
pour la compétition vu le succès
rencontré cette année une deuxième
édition devrait être organisée à plaisir
l'an prochain pour un nouveau tournoi
planant au féminin